so last week John Stewart devoted an
episode of his little watched Apple TV
show to the subject of so-called
transgender rights it was his attempt to
hit back against those transphobic
extremists who believe that human
biology exists now Stuart like so many
other aging leftists is a recent convert
to gender ideology sometime in the last
few years he decided that women could
have penises and men can have babies he
didn't explain his conversion we don't
know if there was a road to Damascus
moment wherein a pregnant man appeared
to him and unveiled the secrets of the
universe or if he experienced some other
sort of vision but he did apologize for
his past acknowledgment of scientific
reality he regrets it deeply and he's
pledged to never make the same mistake
again
Stewart's efforts to debunk biology
consisted primarily of him smirking at
clips of people saying Common Sense
things Stewart of course belongs to that
school of political debate which teaches
that a smarmy grin and a laugh track
qualify as a counter-argument he's not
the only one to employ this strategy his
understudy John Oliver who hosts a
slightly more popular but still little
watched show on HBO has also made a
career out of this same tactic Oliver
has has earned a reputation on the left
for thoroughly demolishing conservative
arguments reputation that is relatively
easy for him to maintain because nobody
actually watches his show to find out if
it's accurate or not if they did they
would see that his manner of demolishing
an argument is to deliver a series of
the most standard and banal left-wing
talking points imaginable couched in
lies and half-truths but these rants
apparently still count as an epic
Smackdown because Oliver is extremely
snide I mean even even more snide than
your usual leftist I mean peppers in a
few lame punch lines plenty of vulgarity
and also has a British accent indeed the
tagline of Oliver's Show could be and
for all I know is Last Week Tonight with
John Oliver the same stuff you hear on
MSNBC except British and with the f word
on Sunday Oliver decided to follow his
mentor's lead and bring his brand of
snide propagandizing to the trans debate
he spent 30 minutes addressing what he
describes as quote a tax on transgender
rights and the left ensures us that the
entire segment is a brilliant
breathtaking
bulletproof defense of their position
and a devastating takedown of the other
side
the same was promised of Jon Stewart's
attempt a week prior only to discover
that the devastating takedown was the
rhetorical equivalent of an
over-inflated balloon that only took the
slightest pin prick to burst the whole
thing so does Oliver fare any better
yes they're both named John they're both
wildly overrated they're both
insufferable smug little Muppets who
imagine themselves to be about 65 IQ
points smarter than they really are but
does that mean that they will fail both
of them miserably in their attempts to
engage with critics of gender ideology
well the answer of course is yes but
don't take my word for it I will go
through now
um John Oliver's segment piece by piece
so that you can see for yourself
Oliver Begins by calling out the I don't
know one or two Democrats in the country
who are not yet fully committed members
of the gender ideology cult and we'll
start there as well
there are many on the left who seem at
best reluctant to engage on this issue
and at worst outright hostile to it
either complaining about pronoun police
or arguing that this issue will cost
Democrats elections if you go to the
middle of the country people would say
if your conversation during a
presidential election is about some guy
wearing a dress and whether he she or it
can go to and and go to the locker room
with their daughter that's not a winning
formula for most people wow it Michael
Bloomberg all the way off with that but
also while this fun-sized billionaire is
clearly good at a lot of things like
making money and end of list maybe don't
take advice on a winning formula for
elections from a man who spent over a
billion dollars of his own money to lose
a presidential bid in just 14 weeks
now first of all it is the grammatically
correct gender-neutral pronoun
a human being who is neither male nor
female if such a creature existed which
it doesn't
would indeed be an it it is a singular
pronoun whereas they in most cases is a
pronoun that indicates multiple
individuals now is it dehumanizing yes
obviously it is but a person who rejects
their male or female identity has
already dehumanized themselves or itself
to be human is to be male or female
there are no other options if you reject
that then you reject your Humanity you
have dehumanized yourself also as far as
Michael Bloomberg goes Michael Bloomberg
goes yes his presidential campaign was
in abysmal and often hilarious failure
we can agree on that but the list of
things that he's good at actually
extends Beyond simply making money as
Oliver claims here's one other highlight
on uh Michael Bloomberg's resume
when he was mayor of New York the city
was actually livable and ever since far
left or farther left Democrats anyway
took over it has been a dystopian
crime-ridden hellscape and I think
that's worth noting it's also worth
noting that John Oliver is so thoroughly
wrong about everything all the time that
he just forced me to defend Michael
Bloomberg I already feel like I need to
take a shower we've only made it about a
minute through this thing let's keep
going
let's also remember that it's not
actually the left talking about trans
rights non-stop it's Republicans who see
an advantage in demagoguing this issue
and to ignore them doing that is to
allow them to have real calamitous
impacts on people's lives a few years
ago voice profiled a girl named Kai
shapley and just watch how happy she is
talking about her hopes for a future
until she remembers something that
changes her mood mom says I might grow
up to be the president
yeah what would you change about the
world if you were president
are you able to use the girls bathroom
at school
no they just put security guards up
oh I hate that that is brutal it is so
dark it's genuinely hard to watch
agreed John I mean it is brutal and hard
to watch that is a very young boy who
has been convinced by his parents that
he is a girl
not only that but he is being paraded
around on camera and used as a political
prop he has been made not only trans but
into a trans mascot
very dark indeed
now how do I know that the boy is not a
girl well because a girl is a human
female child and that boy is a human
child but is not female he is male he is
a boy if you have some other alternative
definition for the world girl I'd love
to hear it in fact nothing you say on
this subject John no argument you
present no talking point you put forward
has any meaning or any value or any
significance at all if you cannot or
will not Define the words you're using
now here's something else I know about
that boy aside from the fact that he is
one
the other thing I know John is that is
that being a child being confused and
being raised in an environment which
intentionally Fosters confusion means
that he has no real concept of what a
girl is that means that when he says I
am a girl
statement doesn't mean anything at best
he is trying to express his affinity for
or interest in some of the things that
he Associates with girls the color pink
long hair dolls whatever none of that
actually makes him a girl John and
that's something that he needs an adult
to explain to him unfortunately all the
adults in his life are just as confused
as he is or at least are pretending to
be just like you
jumping ahead a bit Oliver goes after
Abigail schreier who's the author of The
Great Book irreversible damage about the
trans epidemic claiming the minds and
lives of countless adolescent girls but
Oliver sees no issue with millions of
girls suddenly all at once in unison
deciding that they're really boys this
is perfectly normal John Oliver and says
Troy sometimes dresses her argument up
by using the term rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is total it comes from a
study published by a researcher in 2018
hypothesizing that some kids identify as
trans due to peer pressure but it's
worth you knowing that study was based
on a survey of parents not actual trans
kids and it targeted parents from
organizations dedicated to opposing
trans ideology which is instantly
disqualifying it's like citing a study
claiming that all postal workers not
terrifying hell demons sent to attack
your family but then learning that the
researchers only surveyed a collection
of anxious dogs
that's some heavy sampling bias that
clearly skewed your results
and to be very clear there is ample
evidence of gender variance throughout
human history and as far back as
historians have found evidence of trans
people they found trans children as for
the rapid rise in kids identifying as
trans as the writer Julia Serrano has
pointed out when you look at a chart of
left-handedness among Americans over the
20th century you see a massive Spike
when we stopped forcing kids to write
with their right hand and then a plateau
that doesn't mean everyone became
left-handed although there was a rapid
onset South poor dysphoria it means
people were free to be who they were
okay
all of that is should go without saying
nonsense first of all uh we don't need a
study to tell us that rapid onset gender
dysphoria exists any more than I need to
read a study drawing a link between the
proliferation of fast food and obesity
such studies do exist but people with
functioning brains can draw obvious
common sense conclusions without needing
permission from a research paper to do
it trans identification has risen
20-fold in the youngest generation even
that example he gives of left-handedness
which is a red herring if I've ever seen
one that shows what a six percent rise
over the course of decades we're talking
about 20-fold in the course of a few
years
we went from almost nobody being
confused about their gender to huge
swaths of young people being confused
about their gender
that is rapid
it is gender dysphoria it seems that
calling it rapid onset gender dysphoria
makes a lot of sense
Oliver takes issue with the study uh
that coins this phrase questioning its
credibility on the grounds that the
researchers only surveyed the parents
instead of the quote trans kids
yes because you're not likely to get a
clear or accurate answer if you ask a
child whether they're doing something
because of peer pressure
see the children also aren't fully
cognizant of their own motivations if
you go up to a child and say are you
only doing that because of peer pressure
you're not likely to get a clear answer
because it's a child
as a parent you should be better
equipped to explain your child's
Behavior then your child is himself this
is the Insight that comes with age and
maturity for some of us anyway obviously
not for you John Oliver also says that
the study is unreliable because the
people who conducted it were allegedly
biased
now that may or may not be true I don't
know anything about the study it doesn't
matter to me I don't need the study to
observe what I can clearly see all
around me but then John goes on through
the whole rest of his diatribe to quote
studies and experts who not only have
clear left-wing biases I mean all of
them every single person that he cites
as an authority every single one has a
clear left-wing bias in that very same
clip at the end he cites a left-wing
activist about the about the left-handed
thing
but not only that
not only do most of his authority
figures have left-wing biases they also
have a financial stake in promoting and
defending gender ideology
so he shows no concern for conflicts of
interest in those cases
in fact just like Jon Stewart his entire
defense of the mutilation and castration
of children is that the people making
money off of these procedures think it's
a good idea
that is the entirety of his argument he
has no other argument
as for the quote ample evidence of
gender variance throughout human history
well I went and read the article that he
cites because you know he puts the
quotes up there on the screen and what
you're supposed to do is just see the
quote and then say to yourself well he
had a quote on the screen it must be
true but I actually went and looked at
that National Geographic article and
what I've I found as always is that it
points to examples from history of
spiritual and religious practices
where a man acts out the part of a woman
okay that is not the same as a man
claiming to actually be a woman
it's not even close to the same it's not
even the same sort of thing
unless John you're admitting that
transgenderism today is a religious and
spiritual conviction
because those are all of the historical
comparisons that you are making
for the thousandth time there has never
been ever in history not once not
anywhere
a culture that believed that men could
literally physically be woman women and
vice versa ours is the only civilization
that has ever believed in pregnant men
there is no precedent for that in
history anywhere
one other point John uh later in the
show
cites the high rates of suicide among
trans kids he says that suicidal
ideation is as high as 57 I believe it
says 57 percent almost 60 percent
for quote unquote trans kids now he
blames this on a lack of affirmation
he says indeed the the consequence of
not affirming trans kids is that uh many
will kill themselves
he also says that the reason there were
not millions of trans kids historically
is that they were not free to be who
they effing were
well according to him then
as I've pointed out many times
there should be historically evidence of
millions and millions and millions of
kids all over the world every year for
thousands of years killing themselves
that's how you connect those dots
High rates of suicide if you don't
affirm there were millions and millions
of trans people through history that
were not Affirmed
and yet no such evidence exists it
didn't happen
kids only started killing themselves in
significant numbers now
in modern times in correlation with the
rise in trans identifications so what
does that tell you John
can you turn the laugh track down for a
moment and think clearly about this it's
not very hard to connect the dots
we'll play one more clip Oliver
eventually gets around to offering a
defense of so-called gender affirming
care and let's hear what that sounds
like
at the onset of puberty an adolescent
and their family might consider puberty
blockers hormones that delay puberty and
importantly if that treatment is
suspended then puberty will resume
meaning that this is reversible think of
it like a pause button the thing you
can't do easily on the HBO Max app now
the next potential medical intervention
is usually hormone therapy which boosts
levels of testosterone or estrogen
opponents of gender affirming care make
a lot of alarmist claims about hormone
therapy from saying that it's
experimental which it is not to arguing
that it sterilizes people and look for
some in specific situations there can be
risks to fertility but for others the
effect is anticipated to be reversible
if the medication is discontinued but
there is definitely an informed decision
to be made there you will notice that
none of what I've mentioned so far is
surgery but when it does come to that
some teens may be eligible for instance
for Top surgery or chest masculinization
but you should know not only is that
pretty rare it like all of this would
only happen after a team of medical
professionals discussed all of its risks
and benefits with their patient and
their patient's parent or Guardian all
of whom would have to sign off it is a
long involved process even before you
get to the fact that it's also
incredibly expensive which is why
working-class families families of color
and people with less resources are way
less able to access it basically no kid
is casually dropping into an operating
room because they just decided to get
their uterus removed with the impulsive
recklessness normally associated with
getting bangs because that is at
absolutely ridiculous thing to say
yes it is a ridiculous thing to say John
which is why nobody is saying it you
have very impressively torched a straw
man but let's get back to the reality
first John claims that puberty blockers
are totally reversible and merely put a
pause on puberty this is simply a lie
I'm not going to speculate about whether
John Oliver is smart enough to know that
it's a lie everything he says can be
explained either by his idiocy or his
utter lack of Integrity but it's
impossible to know which aspect of his
personality is flaring up at any given
moment what we can say is that the NHS
used to claim that puberty blockers are
reversible they had it on their website
if you go to the website now it's not
there they removed that claim from their
website and they now admit that in fact
they don't really know anything about
the long-term effects of these drugs on
kids why don't they know well because
we've never put millions of physically
healthy kids on this kind of drug regime
before so we don't know there's no way
to know for certain what the long-term
effects are anyone who claims they know
is lying
these kids are being experimented on we
don't yet have the full results of the
experiment it is ongoing right now
yet Common Sense would tell us that all
drugs have side effects especially those
that intentionally interfere with the
natural physical development during
childhood
you cannot pause the human body like you
pause a television John which by the way
it's not that hard to figure out how to
pause uh on HBO Max I'm not even sure
what you're talking about this is not
science fiction okay human being human
bodies can't just hang out in a state of
suspended animation without consequence
that's not how it works
Oliver then acknowledges that um
hormone therapy for children does
sterilize them but he just kind of hand
waves it away and assures us that for
some uh sure there are kids that are
being sterilized but but for some the
effects of the drugs are anticipated to
be reversible if the medication is
discontinued in time that has a lot of
qualifiers
a lot of qualifiers attached to that
sentence in other words yes it
permanently damages a child's body
permanently sterilizes them but that's
okay because sometimes potentially maybe
it won't harm them as much if they stop
it before the worst side effects set in
in other words Oliver knows that the
drugs harm kids but he doesn't care
he takes the same approach to mutilation
surgeries on minors assuring us that
there are no genital surgeries happening
to kids under the age of 18 which is
just a lie and then he also says that
chest masculinization otherwise known as
double mastectomy only happens if all
the people who will make money on the
procedure say that it should happen
this is the best defense that Oliver can
offer
it's not only dishonest and deceptive
and strikingly stupid but also morally
horrifying
and notice the two questions that Oliver
avoids
he never grapples with the issue of
consent
can a child under the age of 18 actually
consent to any of this
can a 14 year old consent to taking a
drug that will likely sterilize him can
a 15 year old girl consent to having her
breasts removed
Oliver spends 30 minutes dancing around
the subject but never once offers his
own theory of consent of course he
doesn't because he doesn't want to be on
the record arguing that a 14 year old
can consent because he knows how
horrifying and creepy and disturbing
that would sound
but he also doesn't want to be on the
record acknowledging that these things
are happening to kids without their
consent
the question of consent presents an
impossible problem for his side of the
argument and he knows it so he ignores
it
which makes literally everything he says
on the subject of quote gender affirming
care for minors irrelevant as he is
Slithering around and avoiding one of
our primary and most fundamental
objections to it
but
there's an even more fundamental
objection which he also avoids
and that is this
it is not true that a boy can be a girl
or a girl can be a boy
it is not true that gender is fluid
gender ideology is false it does not
reflect the actual reality that we find
ourselves situated in
John Oliver like every other
propagandist on that side simply leaps
over this point but you can't leap over
it we're not challenging your views
simply on the basis that it causes harm
to people though that is one of our most
important objections we are challenging
its factual validity
okay we are saying that it is not true
and so if you have any hope of even
coming close to debunking any of our
arguments you must begin by defending
the fundamental proposition that a male
can be a woman and a female can be a man
if you skip that question
then you skip the whole debate John
just as people skip your show on HBO Max
because unlike you apparently they're
smart enough to work a remote
the pause button is right there in the
middle for future reference
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]